for the first time this year the number  one issue on the minds of american  voters as we head into the midterms is  not  the economy it's not inflation it's not  anything  having to do with their personal  finances  the number one issue  or i should say the most popular issue  for american voters because it's only at  14 but everything is lower than that or  sorry 21 but everything else is lower  than that  is  threats  to democracy  21 a plurality of voters  say the number one issue they have on  their minds right now heading into the  midterms  are the growing threats  to democracy  it's not surprising is it  because what i think this really tells  us  is  the january 6 hearings have worked